[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Волинь
Рівне]
Усе почалося з ательє.
[Оксана Свентах
Співзасновниця S-CAPE]
Ми вже близько десяти років
займаємося пошиттям одягу.
Наша команда завжди намагалися
знайти щось цікаве для себе,
створити продукт, який був би корисним.
І придумали S-CAPE.
Насправді, ми любимо подорожувати:
часто їздили на різні музичні фестивалі.
Подорожували просто Україною,
ходили в гори та їздили закордон.
Ми шукали для себе дощовик.
Хотіли купити, але не знайшли потрібного.
В Україні щось із цим складно було.
І вирішили спробувати пошити.
Зрозуміли, що на ринку цього немає.
До того ж, ми мали ще й досвід пошиття.
Спершу спробували пошити маленьку курточку,
і поїхали на маркет, там вона сподобалася людям.
[Наталія Алєксєєвич
співзасновниця S-CAPE]
Потім ми відкрили вже сторінку у Фейсбуці
і почали потрошки її розвивати.
Побачили, що є попит на цю справу
та після того почали розробляти нові моделі,
і дедалі активніше тим займатися.
Кожну річ дівчата шиють від початку до кінця.
Зараз четверо дівчат у нас шиє,
але в зимовий сезон ми самі не справляємося,
бо обсяги більші.
Ми віддаємо на більшу фабрику і там,
протягом декількох тижнів,
нам відшивають велику партію
на цілий зимовий сезон.
Коли ми замовляли на фабриці, то їздили
туди щодня і перевіряли кожен елемент.
Нам пощастило, що ми їх знайшли,
бо до того в нас був довгий процес пошуків.
Об'їздили багато місць в Рівному,
де можна відшивати
і знайшли дуже хороших підрядників,
з якими ми тепер постійно співпрацюємо.
Ми доповнюємо одна одну.
Наталка є дизайнером, вона більш творча,
часто трохи неорганізована.
Я більш раціональна, рахую, думаю,
скільки і що саме нам потрібно.
Завдяки цьому у нас такий тандем,
що ми доповнюємо одна одну.
Насправді, мені здається, що це не так просто знайти саме такий продукт,
який би гарно продавався.
Це досить довгий шлях.
Тому що ми теж не одразу курточки
і дощовики відшивали.
Ми спочатку пробували шити торбинки, сумки.
Ми відшивали невеличкі колекції одягу,
де були жіночі сукні.
Ці спроби були не зовсім вдалими.
І потім, маючи досвід таких спроб, ми знайшли саме цей продукт.
Тому, я думаю, що багато хто пробує і шукає,
але йому ще не вдається знайти саме той продукт.
Це не так просто.
Тут у нас офіс.
Три комп'ютери і три дівчинки,
[сміються]
три столи і три чашки.
Тут ми роздумуємо, робимо накладні на Нову пошту,
приймаємо замовлення із сайту,
відповідаємо на дзвінки, вибираємо тканини.
Ось до нас багато таких зразків цікавих приходить
різних відтінків, дехто може навіть не побачить їх.
Насправді, ось це все чотири різні кольори.
Дуже складно побачити різницю, але вона є.
Також думаємо про те,
щоб колір підходив чоловікам і жінкам.
Колір — це, насправді, дуже складний момент у створенні колекції.
Ми дуже уважно до цього ставимося.
Цікаві в нас ще стосунки із чорним кольором:
ми взагалі намагались відмовитися
від нього абсолютно,
тому що чорного є дуже багато на ринку.
Ми робили все лише яскравим, кольоровим,
але люди запитували за нього і
просили зробити щось у чорному кольорі.
Ми ухвалили рішення, що здаємося.
[сміються]
І спробували минулого сезону
пошити одну чорну куртку.
Самі тестували її та носили по черзі.
І побачили, що вона дійсно вийшла дуже стильною,
все-таки цей колір додає чогось особливого.
Насправді, у Рівному в нас лише виробництво,
а всі клієнти — у Києві.
Те, що ми далеко від них,
створює певний дискомфорт,
але більше ми працюємо як інтернет-магазин.
Посилка до Києва йде один день,
тож це не проблема.
Хотілося б, звичайно, щось своє в Києві:
чи офіс, чи шоу-рум.
Ми б хотіли й івенти влаштовувати,
якісь зустрічі з клієнтами.
Ну, то це все треба там робити, відповідно.
Але тут в нас, власне, було і є виробництво,
і хороші майстри, які залишилися.
Насправді, це не так легко — знайти майстрів.
Хотіли б трошки розширити асортимент,
але щоб він не надто виходив
за межі нашої концепції:
верхній одяг, захист від дощу та негоди.
Щоб почати шити щось нове,
потрібно зануритися повністю у деталі фурнітури.
Коли хочеш почати працювати з футболками,
то потрібно знати все про трикотажний матеріал
і про те, як наносити друк.
Там є своя специфіка і має пройти трохи часу,
щоб усе це дослідити.
На цьому ми вже спеціалізуємося
і тому впевнені в тому,
що можемо зробити якісно,
бо знаємо усі матеріали.
Наша команда може ще розвиватися у цьому, вдосконалювати цю технологію.
Нам є куди рости у цьому напрямі.
Цікаво було б робити щось новітнє
з використанням сучасних тканин,
що реагують на дотик,
в які можна вмонтовувати гаджети.
Можливо, підемо  у такому напрямі.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Монтажерка
Ліза Літвіненко]
[Музика
Blooms Corda]
[Субтитрувальниця
Ярина Фаюра]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]